(bouncy piano music)
- [Narrator] Kenenisa
Bekele is one of the world's
fastest marathon runners.
He runs the 26.2 miles in half the time
it takes the average runner.
- [Narrator] He has
explored the boundaries
of human potential and
pushed his body to places
that only few could ever dream of.
Every year, the world's
top marathon runners
come to the Berlin Marathon
with hopes of breaking
the world record, running a marathon
under two hours, two
minutes, and 57 seconds,
and in 2016, Kenenisa almost beat it.
- [Narrator] While other cities
host marathons each year,
the world's leading runners
have their sights set
on this particular track.
- [Narrator] The human body
is not built to run marathons
at Kenenisa's desired speed,
so for the last 15 years,
Kenenisa has been
putting in the hard work,
training twice a day, every day.
But pushing his body to unthinkable limits
means the possibilities
of getting hurt are high.
- [Narrator] And Kenenisa
shows no signs of slowing down.
He continues to explore his body's limits
in the hopes of achieving
his ultimate goal.
(lively, bouncy music)
(audience cheering)
(bell chiming)